les fondations des bâtiments sont
désormais ancré dans un sol en partie
liquéfié le séisme transforma la terre
en soupe
nous sommes impuissants devant les
forces de la nature
je me console en me disant que je ne
pouvais rien y faire nous vivons
seulement à deux dans cette maison nous
pensons vivre avec d'autres gens
maintenant même dans des logements
temporaires pour un temps seulement
toutes les maisons ici ont été détruites
le second jour le premier jour la route
a commencé à se dégrader
trois arbres et un poteau électrique
sont tombés sur ma maison
né vers la terre mes jambes tremblent de
peur
autour d'assaut les terres solide se
liquéfiait engloutissant route et
voitures et faisant même basculer les
bâtiments restés sur le sol meuble ce
processus de liquéfaction constitua la
part la plus destructrice de la
catastrophe
les scientifiques se sont depuis
longtemps et forcé d'étudier ce
phénomène mais les chercheurs
s'accordent maintenant à dire que
beaucoup de leurs modèles présentent des
imperfections échoue à donner une
représentation exacte des conditions
réellement existante
une liquéfaction survient généralement
dans les sols sableux quand le sable
remue pendant la secousse
la pression fait que le sol devient
liquide sur la cause des affaissements
du sol les maisons se penche comme celle
derrière nous car le sol ne pouvait plus
la supporter le terrain ici à la
particularité géologique d'être
recouverte de cendres volcaniques qui se
sont accumulés sur les pans de la
montagne au beau milieu de la tourmente
et de la confusion une équipe de
sismologues japonais c'est de comprendre
les structures tectonique du lieu et les
forces en mouvement
regardez cette zone
ça s'est transformé en un escalier le
sol est très mou je pense que lorsque
des gros morceau de terrain ont glissé
dans sa surface a continué à glisser
n'est pas souvent qu'on voit une
montagne s'effondrer comme ça
le japon vit en permanence sous la
menace de nouveaux séismes et éruptions
volcaniques
le pays entier est sous la surveillance
constante des sismologues et des
volcanologues 20% des séismes que subit
notre planète touche le japon chaque
année autour de 600 séisme par an